unfamiliar fishes Sarah Vowell is our
guest Sarah Vowell this is about the
history of Hawaii in a generic sense how
did you get interested in the history of
Hawaii well it's really it's really
about the history of America's
relationship to Hawaii so the first time
I went there I went to see Pearl Harbor
and just as a tourist I'd always wanted
to see that and then I while I was there
I went to see the old palace of the
Hawaiian monarchy and realized that
those two sites are related because you
know the Japanese never would have
attacked Honolulu Harbor for being part
of the United States if the United
States and descendants of American
missionaries hadn't overthrown the
Hawaiian queen who lived in that palace
and handed over the islands to the u.s.
so I guess that was sort of the start of
my interest in the relationship between
the two countries well took us back
there when did the missionaries first go
to Hawaii
they left Boston Harbor they were New
England Calvinists that they left Boston
Harbor in 1819 and arrived in Hawaii in
1820 and also in 1819 the first new
england whalers also from the Boston
Harbor area arrived because Hawaii was a
great stopping off point between whaling
grounds so these two groups of New
Englanders arrived in the Hawaiian
Islands within about you know six months
of each other and they these two groups
had such an enormous impact on the
islands what happened well the
missionaries they set up shop and they
settled down and said about
Christianizing and westernizing the
Hawaiians and teaching more or less the
entire population to read after they had
invented a Hawaiian written language and
translated the Bible into that language
and and so they they were well
established and well-acquainted with the
Hawaiian monarchy the Whalers they
they were sailors on leave basically
every time they came to Hawaii because
they would stop off between the whaling
grounds off Peru and Japan and so Hawaii
became their like our in our spot and
the Whalers and the missionaries though
they were all basically you know from
within about a hundred miles of Boston
they frequently clashed in and in that
era just because they had kind of
differing goals you know the
missionaries were trying like hell to
get the Horn monarchy to do things like
outlaw prostitution and regulate liquor
and when sailors on leave came to the
Hawaiian Islands liquor and the company
of women were kind of high priorities
for them so there was so the Hawaiians
at this time kind of get sort of the
worst of America you know they get the
like you know they get our Puritans and
they get our sailors on leave Sarah
Vowell is our guest this is her most
recent book unfamiliar fishes she's
written several other books the wordy
shipmates about the Puritans again and
we're gonna put the numbers up on the
screen 202 is the area code 737 triple
zero one if you live in the East and
central time zone and would like to talk
with historian Sarah Vowell 737 triple
zero two for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zone Journal
at c-span org is our email book TV at
c-span org is our email address and
twitter.com slash book TV is our hit
Twitter handle Sarah Vowell would you
call yourself a historian no I would not
I'm a writer who writes about history my
I I like to tell stories about history
but stories being the operative word
these are narratives and they're not I
mean they're they're nonfiction so
they're factual or I hope they are but
my goal is are to have personal
interactions with historic sites I do a
lot of reporting I'm the kind of
journalist still and so a lot of what I
do is just you know hanging out talking
to locals I mean my book tells the
history of American
in the Hawaiian Islands but I also will
do things like rent an apartment in the
building where Jack Lord stands on top
of in the opening credits of Hawaii
five-o and talk about that but also talk
about how that building relates to the
history of Americans in Hawaii so a lot
of what I do is kind of placing history
within the context of the present and
you know go to a lot of sites and talk
to the people on the ground when did you
find that Congress first became
interested in the Hawaiian Islands
there's a reference in your book to
President John Tyler in 1842
yeah well like it's interesting our
relationship with Hawaii and you know it
was discovered by Europeans officially
in 1778 by Captain Cook and this is
right around the time that George
Washington is holed up at a Valley Forge
you know and so immediately anyone wants
to pin he's the one who put Hawaii on
the map and anyone who takes a look at
that map and sees where these islands
are they're halfway between the west
coast of the United States and the great
market that is China and you know the
rest of Asia it's obvious that these
islands could be very important stopping
off point and important in terms of
trade with Asia so once once they're on
the map any any man with cash register
rings it you know in his ears
kind of covets them and the United
States
you know sees the islands as being
obviously important in terms of
strategic location and commercialism I
mean like in terms of you know the New
England shipping industry and commercial
whaling it's just obvious from the
get-go that these islands are going to
be very valuable and very crucial and
the Tyler administration they're they
recognized the Hawaiian Islands as as a
as a monarchy as a kingdom and but it's
interesting at that time because
Americans were there so early
you know 1820 we hadn't even settled
West yet and you know later on in the
1840s as we start pushing westward and
start settling Oregon and California and
then the gold rush happens what the New
England missionaries accomplished in
Hawaii which was to Christianize them to
build churches and schools and to turn
try to turn Hawaii into these little New
England communities a lot of people on
the East Coast of the United States
senators and government officials as
well as businessmen see the example of
what the missionaries have accomplished
in Hawaii as perhaps being inspirational
to what we could do on the west coast of
the United States you know the
missionaries they brought their wives
and there's something they saw that the
example of what happened in Hawaii as
you know these preachers and their wives
exerted this you know westernizing
influence on these islands that you know
people hoped could happen on the west
coast of the United States Sarah Vowell
is our guest in the first call up for
her comes from Freeland Michigan good
morning you're on book TV on c-span -
hello thank you very much I asked Miss
Powell
if she thinks that this westernization
of Hawaii was more religious and
cultural on what they call the white
man's food and or was it more just
commercial just people basically wanting
to make money
commercialization versus the white man's
burden Peter man you don't have to
choose you know I mean you because you
have these missionaries and you have
these commercial sailors you have both
things going on at once I mean those
missionaries especially the early ones
they weren't quite idealistic and and
they accomplished a lot just in terms of
literacy so culturally I mean the
interesting thing about what they did
besides teaching more or less the entire
population to read within a generation
in the middle of the 19th century Hawaii
was maybe the most literate country on
earth because of their efforts so
and as a consequence they those
missionaries taught the first generation
of Hawaiian writers and historians to
write and so at the same time they're
trying to dismantle some of the
traditional Hawaiian culture especially
in terms of religion and mores and dress
you know the missionaries had quite a
problem with the Hawaiians way of dress
or lack thereof so so there's that but
because they taught the first generation
of writers and historians to write we
have we have quite impressive records of
the old culture so a lot of and because
of their invention of the written
language a lot of the old Hawaiian
language was preserved so there's that
that's a kind of interesting paradox but
then because you have all the whalers
arrived and then the their arrival kind
of coincides with the heyday of whaling
in the middle of the 19th century they
completely changed over the islands in
things like agriculture Hawaiian farmers
started growing products that American
sailors wanted to eat potatoes cattle
things like that the commercial
development of the waterfronts
especially in Honolulu and and in
Lahaina on Maui you know and and there's
this reciprocal relationship going on
with for instance the west coast of the
United States the Hawaii
the Honolulu Waterfront was built using
timber from the Pacific Northwest so the
change in terms of the culture both
commercially and in terms of religion
was was radical and it had to do with
both the the Christians and the the
sailors serve all why was a year 1898 so
important Ike I mean that is the year of
the spanish-american war it's also the
year that the United States annexes
Hawaii and takes over the Philippines
invades Cuba and the Philippines takes
over Guam and Puerto Rico it's the year
we became an empire and it's really the
year we became who we are now
you know Hawaii is part of that it's and
there was a huge debate at the time
because you know Americans we love to
bicker and a lot of the people who
objected to to becoming an empire to
acquiring colonies saw it as a betrayal
of our original ideals and the ideal of
government based on consent of the
governed the majority of the Hawaiian
population did not want to become an
American territory the Philippines who
had been our allies fighting against
Spain in the spanish-american war when
we acquired the Philippines as as spoils
of that war
our old allies the Filipino Rebelo
started pointing their guns at us and
who could blame them and so we you know
we took over those islands and colonized
them and they became our property and
same thing with Hawaii and so that's
really a corner that we turned in this
country that you know there's no turning
back from that and it was kind of this I
mean really I see it as a question of
people of deciding do we does this
country want to be good or doesn't want
to be great and you have people like
Theodore Roosevelt's and his crony Henry
Cabot Lodge and and men in the
government and the military who saw
greatness as Empire who wanted to build
up the Navy who wanted to acquire these
islands specifically to use as naval
stations to support a Navy to become an
old-style european-style empire and they
saw that as greatness and they won and
we live in their country you know and
and so whatever you think about that on
one side or the other and they're ments
for either position that's the moment
when that happened and we're we you know
we're steel we're still dealing with the
ramifications of that next call for
Sarah Vowell comes from right here in
Washington DC
you're on book TV please go ahead hi
Jamie
I heard all your books and I'm wondering
if you're working on anything at the
moment or what we can expect from you
and in the coming months or years
hmm I don't know if I want to give
anything away just yet I'm kind of
thinking about architecture but you know
I'm not ready to talk I'm not you know
I'm not ready to talk about that yet
well give us if you would a synopsis of
what the board he shipmates is about oh
that was uh that was my book about the
founding of the Massachusetts Bay Colony
in 1630 and so really kind of boiled
down to this and also it's about the
founding of Rhode Island after one of
the Massachusetts Bay Colony Roger
Williams gets booted out of
Massachusetts by his Puritan brethren
for being kind of a rabble rousing
loudmouth and he goes on to found Rhode
Island so it's sort of about it deals
with the two things the two things I
admire most about the American Puritans
are sort of hinted at in that title
because I love them as thinkers and
writers and you know my favorite one of
my favorite pieces of writing Everest
John Winthrop sermon a model of
Christian charity the one where he
imagines New England as a city upon a
hill and so I love them as thinkers and
writers there I think one reason I
wanted to write about them and their
writing is because when someone says
Puritan people think of them as stupid
and these were some of the most educated
intelligent abstract thinkers of all
time they just happened to be born
before the age of reason and then the
other thing I love about them that is
also at the heart of Winthrop sermon is
they're they're they're communalism
their love of one another and the idea
of community and Winthrop sermon is this
kind of poem of community where he says
you know we we must we must be as
members of the same body to rejoice
together and suffer together and mourn
together as members of the same body and
there's something so beautiful and
idealistic about that but it's also the
source of you know his dark side and the
whole dark side of that community is
that anyone who stuck out or spoke out
or you know anyone who
didn't conform to their narrow ideas and
ideals these people were kicked out they
were banished one guy had his ears cut
off so the dark side of that community
is as a refusal to tolerate the ideas
and ideals of others so it's I think a
fairly even-handed portrait of them but
there are things about them that I do
admire where'd you grow up I was born in
Oklahoma and lived there until I was 11
and then the rest of time I grew up in
Montana next call for Sarah Vowell comes
from Boone North Carolina good morning I
like everything you write corporation
played in the overthrow of the Queen in
Hawaii oh the dole corporation you're
talking about dole pineapple that came
later the the dole who founded the the
pineapple plantations he was a distant
relative of Sanford dole who was one of
the missionary descendants who helped
overthrow the Queen and he became the
president of the Republican Republic of
Hawaii the short-lived sort of
government in between the Hawaiian
Kingdom and and Hawaii becoming American
territory so there's no real
relationship there other than they were
kind of distant cousins I think but
Sanford dole is a very interesting
figure and you know his father was a
missionary his father was the first
teacher at the Punahou school which is
the school founded by the missionaries
to educate missionary children in
Honolulu and that is of course the alma
mater of our President and so it was
interesting to me at the inauguration of
President Obama where he has his alma
maters marching band playing in his
inaugural parade and they're there this
from this school you know founded by
Sanford doles father and Sanford dole
ended up you know overthrowing the Queen
and taking her place as the figurehead
of Hawaiian government and when they
were marching in his inaugural parade
this school's band was playing Aloha
away which was of course a song written
by the Queen being played by the high
school marching band of a school
attended by all the missionary
descendants who overthrew her so I love
irony was that Punahou High School home
go to hoe isn't that where President
Obama attended as well of course and
that was founded by the missionaries any
evidence that the missionaries ever
enjoyed Waikiki Beach or had a picnic or
the early missionaries they're not like
ones to have a good time not really but
they did work very very hard and I
especially became enamored of the wives
because they had to do all the wife
mother nineteenth-century stuff raise
the children make the food but they also
had to you know teach school and their
their their journals are remarkable just
for the amount of complaint and you know
they had reason to complain they had
very hard lives but so if you want if
you want picnic memoirs I would say the
Hawaiian missionaries are probably not
your go-to source but they are
interesting Folsom California you're on
with author and journalist Sarah Vowell
Mike and I read a night you read called
SF nation vacation and I was really
intrigued with the story you told about
Lewis Powell and something that I didn't
understand is that as I were calling
your book they found his skull in a box
in the National Archives or in some
repository was wondering how did it
happen that his skull ended up in a box
and for 150 years nobody thought you
know that's a little odd what is this
well what happened Lewis Powell was one
of the conspirators in the Lincoln
assassination and what happens is if
you're one of the people who plot to
kill the president and other high
government officials and you're executed
they're a little loosey-goosey with what
happens to your remains
so Lewis Powell who was executed for his
part in that conspiracy but I remember
correctly he's the one who stabbed
Secretary of State Seward Powell was you
know hanged along with some of the other
conspirators and somehow his skull ended
up in the Smithsonian amongst all of the
American Indian remains and when the law
was passed to start repatriating those
American Indian remains back to their
tribes the researcher who is going
through all of these bones in the
Smithsonian had I think worked at Ford's
Theater Museum or one of the other
associate historic sites and recognized
Powell's name and so eventually that
skull made it back to Florida where and
was buried near Powell's mother so
that's just one of those strange strange
things so if you want your remains to be
intact
and you know placed in the burial place
of your choice do not plot against the
American government that's just those
are just words to live by
you know Sarah Vowell is our guest here
at the National Book Festival live
coverage from book TV on c-span - last
call for her comes from Salt Lake City
High Salt Lake Hawaiian island European
history by Michener and of course
so tales of South Seas how did you
figure out to become you know with the
real the real facts and the updates and
everything like that and second of all
would you comment about how the
missionaries have affected and you know
they have a college there and all that
thanks for calling well I mean that's
where the facts I mean I write
nonfiction so that's kind of the hand
I've been dealt but with the Mormon
history in Hawaii is really
and one of my favorite people to write
about was this guy Walter Marie Gibson
who who this sort of he wasn't really a
con man but he conned he conned Brigham
Young for instance into sending him to
Hawaii as a mormon representative and he
kind of became for a while there the
head of the Mormon Church in in Hawaii
and the Mormon Saints had settled on the
island of Lanai which even now is you
know probably the sleepiest of the major
Hawaiian Islands and Walter Marie Gibson
though he he his dream was to build an
empire and the Pacific that he would
lead and so his journals and Diaries are
so fascinating just in their
grandiloquence where you know he he's on
this Sheep Meadow in lanai and thinks
he's going to rule the Pacific Ocean and
you know he they're it's just a very
flowery and you know he sees it this
crater where he and these poor Mormons
that he's in charge of live as you know
this crater filled with babies and oil
and memories of me eventually the
higher-ups in Salt Lake got wind of him
and what he was doing he was had a lot
of self-absorbed ideas about what the
Mormons should be accomplishing in
Hawaii and that he they sent
representatives from Salt Lake to Hawaii
to to excommunicate him but he went on
to become the premier of the government
he's the man who built yo Lonni palace
he he actually commissioned the statue
of Kamehameha that we all know in
Honolulu so he ended up having a big
impact on Hawaiian history but the
Mormons themselves recovered from his
leadership and went on to become a very
strong religious presence in the island
and there the Brigham Young campus in
Laie a is you know one of the main
colleges there and they also run the
Polynesian Cultural Center which I
believe might be the main tourist
attraction in the islands so they ended
up doing quite well for themselves
in Hawaii the Mormons for those of you
who didn't get a chance to get through
for Sara Valle
we will invite her back on book TV thank
you very much I love c-span and here is
her most recent book unfamiliar fishes
her next book is thinking about
architecture in some different way well
look forward to that one as well sales
pitch Sarah Vowell has been our guest
for the last half hour as we continue
our live coverage here from the National
Book Festival on the mall in Washington
DC